I'm really proud and honored all of my
family and friends back in America are
like what
when I came on the grounds to rehearse I
was like freaking out I was like those
are royal cows that's a royal pheasant
on the ground that's Royal grass I was
like this is crazy I mean when are you
ever gonna get to be a part of something
like this last time this happened is
over 70 years ago right oh it feels good
it feels it feels Royal and um yeah I'm
I'm really excited my pastor always told
me Nicole you are world class so I just
feel really I feel like I need to bring
it and represent up there and just sing
my heart out he's got that gorgeous you
know crown on so that feels feels very
different and especially since you know
his coronation was yesterday it's gonna
it's really special like it's a historic
moment so um I'm I'm just full of
gratitude and Grace to be here